[Musique]
la révolution française éclata le 14
juillet 1789 avec la prise de la
bastille les mouvements politiques
libéraux et les masses populaires s'unir
dans la rue pour défier la monarchie
absolue qui dirigeait la france depuis
plusieurs siècles
les vieilles idées de hiérarchie et de
traditions succombèrent nouveaux
principes des lumières citoyenneté et
droit inaliénable
les premiers révolutionnaires espérait
réformer le gouvernement avec le roi
bourbon louis saez
mais quand les éléments radicaux ravir
le pouvoir aux modérés la monarchie fut
abolie et la première république
française vit le jour
la france ne connaît en fait que le
système monarchique temps qu'elle
j'allais dire que d'une certaine manière
elle ne peut pas imaginer un autre type
de régime mais elle voudrait en fait une
monarchie plus libérale ouverte aux
nouveautés aux demandes en attente en
fait de la bourgeoisie et du peuple et
elle propose donc aux rois cette
solution mais le roi ne l'acceptera pas
l'europe en futaie jamais changé la
déclaration des droits de l'homme marca
une rupture radicale et transforma du
tout au tout l'état d'esprit de la
population française la famille royale
ne quitta pas la france et ne survécut
pas à ce bouleversement
pas plus que les chefs révolutionnaires
c'est pourquoi même après la disparition
de louis saez et de marie antoinette
il fallut des générations pour que le
projet qu'ils avaient conçu pour la
france soit réalisé en fait le chemin
vers la démocratie ça verra si rude que
près de 35 ans après la naissance de la
république les français restent horaires
la monarchie avec un héritier de la
maison de bourbon louis xviii
contrairement à son malheureux frère
louis saez et à son neveu louis 17 au
destin tragique
louis xviii se trouva au bon endroit au
bon moment
louis saez après avoir été déposé fut
incarcéré avec son épouse marie
antoinette en août 1792 à la prison du
temple à paris
il y avait aussi la outre le roi et la
reine leur fille marie thérèse charlotte
madame royal leur fils louis charles
dauphin de france est la plus jeune
soeur du roi
madame elisabeth le roi fut bientôt
accusé de trahison
puis déclaré coupable et condamné à mort
le 21 janvier 1793
ou les
le monstre
et quand on tombe
[Musique]
il y
pour les royalistes de france et de
l'étranger et pour la plus grande partie
de l'europe
la mort de louis ça signifiait que le
trône de france revenait à louis charles
le dauphin âgé de huit ans selon la
légitimité dynastique il devait succéder
à son père sous le nom de louis 17 le
plus jeune frère de louis saez oncle de
l'enfant
louis stanislas comtes de provence se
déclare à lui-même très vite
réjean de france bien sûr tout cela
n'était que des mots louis charles était
emprisonné en tant qu'ennemi de la
république et le comte de provence comme
tous les émigrés avait été déclarée
traître selon les lois fondamentales du
royaume
on ne peut pas choisir le roi de france
c'est la règle le roi est mort vive le
roi il y a toujours un roi pour succéder
à roy et c'est toujours l'héritier mâle
est né et en l'occurrence c'est le petit
enfant qui est au temple qui est
prisonnier et qui ne peut pas renier
d'abord parce que c'est la révolution
ensuite parce qu'il est prisonnier et 3e
malheur il est malade et il n'empêche
que pour les royalistes
après louis saez c'est louis ducept donc
c'est cet enfant qui devient louis 17 et
il le restera jusqu'à sa mort deux ans
plus tard et dans l'histoire il y a un
enfant roi qui s'est appelé louis 17
le bouleversement qui suivit le régicide
plonge à la nation dans le chaos et
provoqua un mouvement paranoïaque qui
atteignit son comble dans ce qu'on a
appelé la terreur il suffisait qu'un
homme soit simplement soupçonnées de
déloyauté pour qu'ils soient condamnés
par le tribunal révolutionnaire
la plupart des réformes démocratiques
prônée par la révolution furent
suspendus et les exécutions commencèrent
à grande échelle la guillotine inventé
en france est censée être une méthode
d'exécution plus humaines permis
d'envoyer des milliers d'aristocrates à
la mort devant la foule des parisiens
assoiffés de sang dans la capitale les
exécutions se tenait place de la
révolution
ancienne place oui 15 et actuelle place
de la concorde au temple la situation de
la famille royale empirait leur
surveillance renforcée permis de déjouer
des complots royalistes destiné à sauver
l'enfant et sa mère
louis charles qui représentait une
menace pour la révolution fut confié un
couple de gardiens
l'homme ancien cordonnier eu pour
mission de rééduquer l'ancien dauphin et
de lui apprendre à renier la monarchie
et à soutenir la république
le petit prince intelligent et de
caractère enjoué
né dans le magnifique palais de
versailles n'avait connu que le confort
l'amour et la tendresse
après 1789 il a été protégé des dures
réalités de la révolution par les
serviteurs qui lui était dévoué et par
ses parents qu'il adorait il était
encore sous le coup de la mort
inexplicable de son père lorsqu'on le
réveilla une nuit en lui ordonnant de
faire ses adieux à sa mère après de
longues étreintes remplis de larmes il
fut arrachée à ses bras louis-charles ne
revit jamais sa mère née sa soeur
alors le fameux petit louis 17 va vivre
en réalité à peine une dizaine d'années
il n'est en 85 et bon on a fait beaucoup
de théories sur une évasion de la prison
du temple etc mais non il meurt
prisonniers des révolutionnaires c'est à
dire qu'à partir du moment où oussama
mans la reine marie-antoinette est
exécuté il est confié aux mains du
cordonnier simon dans la prison du
temple et là il véritablement traité
comme mais comme comme une bête
il est dans une petite dans un cul de
basse fosse dans une cellule et objets
de de ramper sur le sol pour ouvrir une
trappe pour avoir sa nourriture
à ce rythme là il est malade il souffre
de tuberculose et il meurt
vraisemblablement donc en 95 épuisé
d'une péritonite tuberculeuse marie
antoinette fut transférée à la
conciergerie réservé aux prisonniers de
droit commun lors de la parodie de
procès tenu par le tribunal
révolutionnaire
elle fut très vite déclaré coupable de
trahison est condamné à être exécutés
sur l'ordre de maximilien robespierre
hommes politiques chantre de la terreur
louis charles fut emprisonné dans une
pièce sombre et privé de tout contact
humain pendant six mois on lui passait
sa nourriture par une petite ouverture
pratiquée dans la porte
il fallut attendre que robespierre soit
renversé et devienne lui-même victimes
de la terreur pour que le gouvernement
en place soit informée du traitement
honteux qui était réservé aux petits
dauphins dans la prison du temple
[Musique]
après avoir été plusieurs fois repoussé
une enquête fut diligentée sur les
conditions de détention de l'enfant et
sa situation s'améliorera mais il était
trop tard
il était mourant
il avait été abusée et traités avec une
extrême négligence et le petit prince
autrefois les est en bonne santé et est
devenu méconnaissable ce qui jettera
plus tard le doute sur la véritable
identité de l'enfant prisonniers un
médecin fut enfin appelé à la prison
mais il ne put que soulager les
souffrances de l'enfant louis 17 mourut
le 8 juin 1795 il avait dix ans on
pratique assure lui une autopsie et le
roi qui n'avait jamais renier fut
enseveli sans faste dans une fosse
commune
son frère et son neveu étant mort louis
stanislas comtes de provence alors âgé
de 40 ans fit valoir ses droits à la
succession au trône sous le nom de louis
xviii immédiatement dès l'annoncé de la
mort du dauphin le bruit courut que
l'enfant s'était échappée qu'on avait
fait sortir du temple et qu'un autre
enfant lui avait été substituées
[Musique]
louis stanislas xavier qui reçu à sa
naissance le titre de comte de provence
n'acquittent en 1755 au château de
versailles
il était le fils de louis dauphin de
france seule fille survivante du roi
louis 15 qui ne vécut pas assez
longtemps pour succéder à son père mais
on se souvient de lui comme le père de
trois rois louis saez louis xviii et
charles 10 au moment de sa naissance
louis stanislas était le quatrième dans
l'ordre de la succession au trône
en effet il était le troisième d'une
fratrie de quatre garçons et deux filles
ses frères aînés et et louis joseph et
louis auguste et son cadet charles
philippe il avait également deux soeurs
la princesse clotilde et la princesse
elizabeth
après la mort de son frère aîné et de
son père louis auguste devint dauphin de
france
un an plus tard il épousa la charmante
archiduchesse d'autriche marie
antoinette
quant à lui louis stanislas épousa une
princesse de savoie peu séduisante et
ennuyeuse on rapporte qu'il la trouvait
si repoussante qu'ils n'eurent jamais
d'enfant à la mort de son grand-père
louis 15 en 1774 louis auguste lui
succéda sous le nom de louis saez et
louis stanislas devint le suivant dans
la succession au trône
il adopte un style de vie paisible et
sédentaire il ne partageait pas la
passion des bourbons pour la chasse à
cause de ses passe temps favoris
nourriture et lecture il grossit
énormément si bien que plus tard il
fallut que ses serviteurs le porte deux
nuits dans les escaliers
au cours des débats précédant la
révolution
louis stanislas n'était partisans que
d'une modeste réforme des impôts au
premier signe de révolte au début de
1789 il pressa leroy hésitant à user de
la force contre le coup d'état qui se
préparait
quand les violences éclataient à paris
louis stanislas décida de rester à
versailles et encourage à leroy à faire
de même
son frère charles comte d'artois plus
conservateurs quitte à la france avec
son épouse et ses enfants est établi sa
résidence comme bien d'autres courtisans
à turin
alors pendant la révolution dès le 14
juillet tout le monde s'en va le 15
juillet toute l'aristocratie l'épaule
lignac et c est même le comte d'artois
c'est à dire le frère cadet le benjamin
pardon de louis saez le plus petit dans
la dans la fratrie
tout le monde s'en va fils à l'étranger
on émigre or le second le comte de
provence
le frère cadet de louis saez lui reste à
paris reste en son palais du luxembourg
parce que alors pourquoi pour deux
raisons parce qu'il a plus de cran
peut-être que les autres mais aussi
vraisemblablement parce qu'il a une idée
derrière la tête parce que il se dit mon
frère le roi est en très mauvaise
posture
il est vraisemblable que je sois appelé
à le remplacer et on s'est même qu'il
serait à l'origine d'une conspiration la
conspiration de monsieur du marquis de
favre as pour éloigner louis saez du
trône et pouvoir ainsi devenir roi de
france
quand la famille royale se trouve a
forcé de déménager à paris au palais des
tuileries provence et son épouse
s'établir au palais du luxembourg
il dînait régulièrement avec le roi et
la reine jusqu'à leur fuite à l'issue
malheureuse en 1791
[Musique]
le donc ce jour de juin l'enjoint louis
xviii est informé de la fuite son frère
lui dis nous allons rejoindre monsieur
de bouyer son armée vers le front de
l'est à montmédy
il faut que vous partiez il parle lui
aussi de son côté il type le son palais
du luxembourg en se maquillant se
déguisant en mettant une grosse comme
août noir en salle et ils étaient les
cagouillards il boite igi sautillait on
se mettant une redingote avec bien
afficher sur cette rue des rigoles le
cordon tricolore bien sûr pour qu'on le
prenne pour un révolutionnaire et faut
être cochée lui il arrive à franchir la
frontière paisiblement
cette nuit la provence quitte à paris il
atteignit la frontière et rejoignit son
plus jeune frère et la cour de france
exilé à coblence en allemagne
ben oui stanislas par le même jour que
louis saez en fait on part pas dans la
même direction et perd moins son temps
que louis saez qui s'arrête en route qui
est confrontée à différents accidents de
voiture quelque chose comme ça et il il
file en fait vers les pays bas et il va
ensuite rentré en quelque sorte en
émigration il ne peut pas revenir en
france et il va donc circulé un peu
partout en europe il va aller en italie
on va le retrouver en allemagne en
pologne et finalement en angleterre
avant sa restauration façon ça monte sur
le trône en 1814 louis saez fut
appréhendé au cours de sa célèbre fuite
à varennes
il fut ramenée sous escorte à paris où
il fut bientôt proclamé roi des français
et la monarchie constitutionnelle fut
établie officiellement pressé de
raffermir sa situation
le comte de provence toujours contre les
instructions du roi commence à
échafauder un plan pour envahir la
france il qu'on promettait en toute
connaissance de cause la sécurité du
monarque en organisant une intervention
étrangère contre la révolution avec
l'aide de son autre frère et prince de
bourbon en porte une lourde
responsabilité dans la tragédie qui
conduisit à la mort de leur frère louis
saez et à l'abolition de la monarchie
les autres nations d'europe furent
d'abord satisfaite de voir la france aux
prises avec des luttes politiques
internes
mais quand la famille royale fut
emprisonné au temple tous les monarques
vire dans la révolution une menace
qu'ils pouvaient également s'abattre sur
eux les intérêts des nations était en
jeu tout était prêt pour qu'une guerre
éclate
galvanisé par ses succès sur les champs
de bataille
le gouvernement français proclame a
officiellement la fin de la monarchie et
l'avènement de la république
les princes d'europe restèrent pétrifiés
à la nouvelle de la mort de louis saez
le roi et la reine ayant disparu la
colère du peuple s'abattit sur l'unique
cible qui lui restait le dauphin on fit
endosser à sept enfants innocents et
sans défense
la responsabilité des longues guerres
inutiles du luxe de la cour et des
politiques répressives
louis-charles devint la victime la plus
lamentable de la révolution à la mort de
son neveu l'ambitieux comtes de provence
qui était à sa naissance quatrième dans
l'ordre de succession au trône devint le
prétendant légitime au titre de roi de
france
mais ces années d'exil ne faisait que
commencer
le pays n'était pas prêt à retrouver un
roi et encore moins un souverain de la
lignée des bourbons
[Musique]
c'est à cette époque qu'un jeune général
républicain du nom de bonaparte
courageux et bien fait de sa personne
ravi le coeur des français
il ne fallut que trois ans à la
révolution pour atteindre son but
les premiers révolutionnaires abolir les
privilèges de classe et confièrent la
souveraineté au peuple
il comptait sur le temps pour améliorer
la constitution et pour acquérir une
meilleure expérience politique
mais dix ans plus tard la france était
encore plongé dans des conflits tant
intérieure qu'extérieure
les querelles de factions et la guerre
contre les puissances étrangères
retardait la construction tangible des
objectifs révolutionnaires la population
commençait à réclamer de pouvoir vivre
dans la paix le pays était sur le point
d'aborder une nouvelle période les
ambitions de trois dynasties rival les
bourbons les orléans et les bonaparte
désireux d'occuper le trône de france
allait plonger le pays dans un cycle
interminable de révolution de campagne
militaire et d'élections mais on a d'une
part les forces de l'ancienne monarchie
les monarchistes en fait légitimiste qui
sont partis qui ont quitté la france
avec la révolution qui sont en
émigration et qui sont très actifs pour
effectivement essayé de reprendre le
pouvoir et de remettre un bonbon sur le
trône
et puis on a aussi des tendances en
france républicaine qui essaie
d'installer un régime nouveau il et on a
le choix entre plusieurs personnages à
l'époque et c'est finalement bonaparte
qui emportera le morceau
le premier à initier ce changement et
napoléon bonaparte un jeune général
corse très populaire qui sut profiter
des opportunités offertes par la
révolution française
son instinct du souffle que la
population est prête afin de retrouver
la stabilité a sacrifié sa liberté et la
démocratie pour laquelle elle s'est
battue et a accepté que les rênes du
gouvernement soit aux mains d'un homme
fort il renverse le directoire qui
gouvernait la république par le fameux
coup d'état du 18 brumaire
c'est ainsi que napoléon âgé de 30 ans
est porté à la tête de la nation et
devient premier consul il garde pour
objectif de porter la révolution à
l'extérieur du pays
mais à l'intérieur il établit une
dictature militaire et met fin au
mouvement révolutionnaire
en dix ans la france est passée de
l'autocratie à la monarchie
constitutionnelle puis à la république
constitutionnelle et enfin au despotisme
militaire
[Musique]
louis stanislas continue à agir en tant
que louis xviii
son exil se prolonge et ses déclarations
sur son mode de gouvernement tente de
plus en plus vers le libéralisme louis
xviii n'a pas d'enfant mais son frère a
deux fils qui ont grandi en exil et sont
des héritiers présomptifs du trône de
france pour consolider la puissance de
sa famille louis xviii convainc sa nièce
marie thérèse fille de louis saez
d'épouser son cousin louis antoine duc
d'angoulême et il persuade le jeune
couple de venir vivre auprès de lui
marie thérèse est la seule survivante de
la prison du temple louis xviii à
négocier sa libération
peu après l'achèvement de la terreur en
échange de prisonniers français
elle avait été envoyée à vienne dans la
famille de sa mère louis trompe sa nièce
en lui disant que les dernières volontés
de ses parents était de la voir mariée à
son cousin louis xviii quitte
l'allemagne pour l'italie
puis et chassé vers l'est en russie
grâce à la générosité du tsar paul
premier il rebâti avec sa famille
élargie une cour au style de vie aussi
luxueux que celui de versailles dans le
palais de mythos en lettonie
mais en 1801 le tsar annuler la pension
qu'il versait aux exilés et les chasses
il trouve alors refuge auprès de la
reine de prusse quand les événements les
force à quitter la prusse
le nouveau tsar alexandre 1er les invite
à réintégrer leurs résidences de mythos
et leur accorde à nouveau une pension
moins généreuse cependant
napoléon préoccupé par les complots qui
vise à restaurer les bourbons tente
d'obtenir de louis xviii qu'il renonce
au trône de france est bien quand il
entend en effet que ni un petit général
qui semble vraiment être efficace
vigoureux intelligent qui s'est emparée
de toulon alors que la ville de toulon
s'était livré aux anglais eh bien il lui
fait savoir une façon courrier à
bonaparte et lui écoutez je vais revenir
comme roi parce que son ambition et ce
sera comme ça éternellement il veut
régner il veut plus je crois qu'il faut
voir cette nuance il veut plus être roi
que régner il veut donc être roi est il
écrit à bonaparte il lui dit écoutez je
vous aimerai lieutenant général du
royaume et bonaparte plus répond tout
simplement si vous venez en france il
faudrait que vous passiez sur cent
cinquante mille cadavres
celui ci refuse et aussitôt napoléon se
couronne lui même empereur des français
il promet à son pays de l'ue a apporté
la gloire après le chaos qu'il vient de
traverser en 1808
la france impériale a conquis la plus
grande partie de l'europe
les plans de napoléon pour redessiner ce
continent englobe également la russie
le tsar prévient les bourbon qui ne peut
plus se porter garant de leur sécurité
et louis xviii et forcé de s'embarquer
pour l'angleterre
de nouveaux dépendant des faveurs de
l'étranger les exilés s'installe à arte
warehouse dans le comté de buckingham où
résident déjà plus d'une centaine de
courtisans les anglais toujours très
pragmatique
considérant qu' il avait droit à des
égards en tant qu'adversaire évident
en de leur ennemi napoléon il avait des
en tant qu'héritier aussi du trône de
france
mais comme il n'avait pas beaucoup de
chance et comme le gouvernement anglais
ne pariez pas un seul penny sur sa ses
chances de revenir au pouvoir
eh bien on lui avait interdit
l'utilisation du titre de roi de france
et et le moindre privilèges de la
noblesse c'est à dire qu'ils n'étaient
pas reçu de la cour d'angleterre et même
un certain moment on a jugé sa présence
encombrante et il a fallu que ce exil
loin de londres après l'un est revenu il
est allé en écosse et une vie d'errance
après le désastre de sa campagne de
russie
napoléon voit sa puissance décliné ses
ambitions lui ont valu de nombreux
ennemis et ont soumis à rude épreuve les
finances du pays
il est vaincu en avril 1814
quand une coalition d'armée européenne
s'empare de paris napoléon est forcée
d'abdiquer et envoyé en exil sur l'île
d'elbe dans l'archipel au score lorsque
la la chute de napoléon on envisage
différentes solutions
certains pensent que la le régime
pourrait être rétablie par le enfin
qu'on pourrait retrouver un régime
impérial avec le fils de l'empereur le
roi de rome
mais c'est finalement dans d'autres où
ce pour la république ça c'est une des
constantes de l'histoire de france tout
au long du xixème siècle
mais la république fait toujours peur
parce que la république c'est la
révolution donc l'anarchie donc on est
toujours très inquiet de sa et notamment
dans les pays voisins
et c'est finalement donc la solution des
bourbons qui apparaît comme la solution
la plus fiable la plus prudente pour la
france et pour ses rapports avec la
communauté internationale
du jour au lendemain les alliés approuve
la restauration de la monarchie des
bourbons
des messagers partout en angleterre pour
informer louis stanislas de l'évolution
rapide du climat politique
après avoir vécu 23 ans en marge de la
société
il devient soudain louis xviii le désir
et celui qu'attend le peuple français
pour redresser le pays
en été il n'est pas vraiment désiré il
est inévitable parce qu'on a personne
d'autre à mettre sur le trône de france
il n'ya cru désiré je crois que le terme
est vraiment excessif selon désiré
surtout c'était la paix la noblesse et
les aristocrates émigrés se réjouissent
le nouveau roi kit douvres pour calais
quand il met le pied sur le sol français
il est accueilli par des foules de
partisans enthousiastes sa nièce marie
thérèse duchesse d'angoulême
irrémédiablement marqué par son séjour
dans la tour du temple est à son côté
lorsqu'ils entrent dans paris par la
porte saint denis dans une voiture tirée
par huit chevaux blancs au cours du mois
louis xviii donne l'ordre d'exhumer les
restes de louis saez et marie-antoinette
de la fosse commune et de les placer
dans la crypte royale de la basilique
saint denis
une messe de requiem et chanter dans les
églises de paris pour louis 17 sa mère
son père et sa tante
l'émotion est grande le roi jouit d'une
grande popularité
car ils tentent d'instaurer une
monarchie parlementaire et de revivifier
un pays appauvri par la révolution et la
guerre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après ces 25 années où la france a connu
la révolution puis l' empire
quelle est la nature exacte de la
restauration va-t-elle pérenniser
l'autoritarisme impériale ou ramener
l'absolutisme de l'ancien régime
louis xviii est un réaliste
nous sommes au 19e siècle la
restauration des bourbons est une
période comme la france n'a encore
jamais connu les idées politiques que le
roi car et c'est dans sa jeunesse ne
sont plus de mise
il veut oublier les transgressions du
passé et embrasser l'avenir la
révolution lui a appris qu'il ne
suffisait pas d'être un héritier
légitime il doit aussi se soucier de la
vie quotidienne de ces sujets qui espère
après avoir connu les ambitions
napoléonienne pouvoir vivre dans la paix
et la prospérité
louis xviii pense être l'homme qui
pourra y parvenir le règne de louis
xviii reflète son désir d'être un
monarque modéré bien qu ils hésitent sur
de nombreuses questions
louis ne doute jamais de sa légitimité
dans tous les domaines il montre qu'il
est le roi
il se fait connaître par la grandeur le
luxe et les cérémonies de sa cour par
son attitude royal c'est manière
paisible l'attention qu'il porte à sa
famille et la crainte qu'il peut
inspirer louer montre également une
grande confiance mais il n'est pas
certain qu ils la ressentent
profondément dans le fait que le temps
est venu pour une politique de
modération
il propose l'amnistié à tous ceux qui ne
se montreront pas opposé à la
restauration et soulignent régulièrement
les bienfaits de la paix de la
prospérité et de la réconciliation
charles comte d'artois qui a tant rêvé
de se venger un jour des usurpateurs et
choqué d'apprendre que son frère n'a pas
l'intention d'être le roi de la
contre-révolution
pour louis xviii le monarque est au
dessus des partis politiques
il a le désir de réconcilier les
différents partis et classes sociales et
des les réunir en hommage au tour de son
trône
cela se reflète dans le choix de ses
ministres qui représente toutes les
tendances du spectre politique
royalistes révolutionnaire et dissidents
il fallait se concilier les grâces des
anciens révolutionnaires
il fallait se concilier les grâces de
taux les dignitaires de l'empiré puis
surtout comme c'était la restauration
turow à trans il fallait que le parti
royaliste accepte la cohabitation avec
la noblesse d'empiré le blesse tout
récent de noblesse de parvenus et avec y
compris avec les assassins du roi parce
que les rôlistes appelait les assassins
du roi c'est à dire les conventionnels
qui avaient voté la mort du roi le roi
restitue à de nombreux noble leurs
revenus et leur titre mais veille
également à ce que l'élite napoléonienne
ne se sentent pas exclus à la cour il
accorde ses faveurs à ceux qui lui sont
utiles et certains disent en 1814 qu'il
vaut mieux être l'ennemi du roi que son
ami les biens de la noblesse et du
clergé ayant été saisi puis vendue comme
biens nationaux
il y avait des gens qui s'étaient rendus
propriétaires de grands domaines de 30
propriété qui s'était au passage
enrichis grâce à la révolution tout le
monde le sait et bien louis xviii s'il
voulait mener une politique de
réconciliation
il fallait qu'il reconnaisse la
propriété de ses biens nationaux à leurs
nouveaux propriétaires et ça a coûté
cher parce que les anciens propriétaires
des biens qui étaient titulaires de
domaine sous l'ancien régime
eh bien eux qu'est ce qu'il a fallu
faire il a fallu les indemniser et tout
ça vous montre à quel point la
restauration a commencé sous le signe de
la complexité administrative et des
grandes dépenses louis pense que le pays
doit se doter d'une monarchie
constitutionnelle
il octroie à ces sujets une charte en
affirmant à ses détracteurs qu'elle
correspond à l'esprit de notre siècle
il aperçoit qu il ne peut plus gouverner
comme gouverner louis xiv absolue et le
regrette mais on est quand même obligé
de lui imposer cette constitution car il
existe maintenant la constitution en
france on a quand même connu une
république en 92
alors il est non c'est pas une
constitution d'abord je ne veux pas que
l'on m'impose constitution c'est moi qui
vais vous proposer une charte
donc cette manière délicate de dire ses
bras quand même qui fait la loi et qui
commande mais il est obligé de respecter
cette charte est surtout de gouverner
avec les parlements parce que maintenant
nous ne sommes plus en moi larcher
absolue mais en archi parlementaire la
charte du 4 juin 1814 va permettre à la
france de connaître sa première
véritable expérience de monarchie
parlementaire et instaure la liberté
d'expression et la tolérance religieuse
l'emprisonnement arbitraire est
également aboli le royaume est devenu un
des pays les plus libéraux et les plus
tolérants d'europe
mais louis fait aussi un certain nombre
de grave erreur politique
il adopte le drapeau blanc des bourbons
et non le drapeau tricolore de la
république
insiste pour porter le titre de roi de
france et non celui de roi des français
il commémore chaque année la mort de
louis saez et de marie antoinette et ne
parvient pas à abolir un impôt
particulièrement impopulaires l'armée
est toujours bonapartiste et pourtant
louis ne prend aucune mesure pour la
réformer cette négligence va avoir des
conséquences extrêmement graves pour lui
l'erreur capitale 18 c'est qu'ils les
106 dans l'armée tous les soldats ou
presque sont licenciés est réduit à demi
soldes c'est à dire la mendicité
si bien que évidemment quand napoléon
aura l'idée de quitter son île d'elbe en
les soldats vont se dire mais vive
l'empereur on va retrouver du travail
quand napoléon apprend que les anciennes
querelles se sont rallumées il voit là
une possibilité de revenir au devant de
la scène toujours audacieux maîtres dans
l'art de saisir le moment opportun
napoléon s'enfuit de l'île d'elbe pour
lancer ce qui est l'un des plus grand
retour au pouvoir de tous les temps avec
quelques centaines d'hommes seulement il
accoste dans le sud de la france et
entreprend une longue marche vers paris
louis xviii envoie des soldats croire et
l avance de napoléon mais lorsqu'ils
retrouvent leur ancien chef
ceci tombe sous son charme baisse les
armes et se joignent à lui tandis qu'ils
se rapprochent de la capitale
le prestige du chef militaire était si
fort que finalement des maréchaux le cas
le plus célèbre étant le maréchal ney
ont finalement trahi le pouvoir de louis
xviii auquel il s'était pourtant mallié
pour rejoindre napoléon et napoléon peut
se réinstaller au pouvoir en france
la population ne résiste pas à l'image
si romantique de l'ancien empereur des
foules se rassemblent pour l'accueillir
les bras ouverts sans la protection de
son armée louis xviii doit choisir entre
la guerre civile et l'emprisonnement
il fut de nouveau la france permettant
ainsi à napoléon porté par
l'enthousiasmé populaire de reprendre le
pouvoir
[Musique]
quand la nouvelle parvient aux
gouvernements étrangers
une coalition se met en place sous le
commandement d'un britannique le duc de
wellington
les forces alliées rencontre les
français en belgique près du village de
waterloo les 100 jours se termine par la
défaite de l'empereur vaincue par les
forces anglaises et prussiennes lors de
la bataille de waterloo
napoléon est envoyé en exil sur le
rocher de sainte-hélène une île
britannique situé au milieu de
l'atlantique sud
des rumeurs selon lesquelles louis
philippe duc d'orléans cousin de louis
xviii aux idées libérales seraient sur
le point de se déclarer héritier du
trône pousse le roi a précipité son
retour à paris et à reprendre les rênes
du pouvoir
quand le roi rentre au palais des
tuileries il est accueilli par une foule
encore plus enthousiaste que l'année
précédente
mais il ne retrouvera pas au cours de
cette seconde restauration
laura qui l'entouraient lors de la
première il a assisté à la désertion de
son armée et à la révolte de la moitié
de ces sujets sa fuite bien que
compréhensible l'a présenté en état de
faiblesse
il revient avec une image amoindri qui
ne pourra s'estomper
à présent le roi doit affronter une
nouvelle humiliation les alliés lui
impose un traité qui l'obligent à
entretenir pendant cinq ans des forces
étrangères d'occupation à verser des
indemnités de guerre et à rendre les
collections d'oeuvres d'art prise par
napoléon dans les capitales européennes
[Musique]
ce ministre faisant pression sur lui
pour qu'il accorde une promotion à
certains traîtres rallier à bonaparte et
pour qu'il révise la constitution le roi
abandonne la plupart de ses devoirs à
son conseil des ministres
des rumeurs à propos de la survie du
dauphin louis 17
l'enfant du temple refont surface ces
questions restées sans réponse entraîne
des doutes sur la légitimité de louis
xviii
mais celui ci résiste à la tempête il
tient bon face aux pressions
réactionnaire de sa famille et confirme
sa volonté d'instaurer une autorité
exécutive une constitution libérale et
un gouvernement centriste pour prévenir
d'éventuelles tentatives de renversement
il réforme et développe la gare de royal
effet placé de grosses sommes d'argent
dans une banque en angleterre ceux qui
ont trahi le roi pour napoléon n'ont pas
d'autre choix que de s'opposer au
gouvernement des bourbons cependant les
menaces et trahison à l'encontre de
louis xviii
lors du bref retour de napoléon ont
renforcé chez beaucoup de sujets un
fervent sentiment royalistes le roi est
devenu sujet d'idolâtrie
louis xviii adopte un style très formel
entrecoupés de brefs moments de
familiarité il montre un grand respect
sans doute accentué par son exil pour
l'argent et la propriété il rassemble
autour de lui une cour raffiné et
entretient une garde aux allures sont en
bois y ante afin que ces sujets est une
haute opinion de lui il se plaît à vivre
dans un environnement luxueux entouré
d'un très grand nombre de serviteurs
dévoués louis xviii se répand en cadeau
opulent auprès des souverains des autres
puissances
il apprécie la décoration et le mobilier
néoclassique laissé par napoléon
les seules modifications qu'ils y
apportent parfois consiste à masquer les
abeilles et l'initiale impériale par son
propre emblème la corne d'abondance pour
louis xviii
les arts de la paix remplacent les
machines de guerre paris redevient comme
avant la révolution
le centre du luxe et de la mode le
mécénat artistique est assurée par le
roi la cour et le gouvernement
malheureusement les deux centres du
pouvoir de cette période
le palais de saint cloud et celui des
tuileries ont aujourd'hui disparu
victimes de violence ultérieure
[Musique]
louis xviii en mauvaise santé depuis des
années commence à décliner au printemps
1824 ils souffrent d'obésité de gouttes
d'artériosclérose généralisée et la
gangrène gagne son corps obèses et
impotent louis xviii pouvait peser
quelque chose comme 130 kg on le
surnommait le pot dagrou le goût tu
étais dans un
c'est sa faute aussi parce qu' il ne
pouvait pas s'empêcher d'être fort ah si
laval et trois poulets il buvait deux
bouteilles de bourgogne dès qu'ils
avaient l'occasion
donc il mangeait comme un goinfre il
était devenu eneurope ventripotent
souffreteux c'est quand on lui enlevait
ses bottes à la fin de sa vie on
enlevait également des morceaux de peau
des morceaux de chair à l'intérieur des
bottes tellement ils étaient gangréné on
ne pouvait plus lui parler il était
ravagé par la gangrène
il est des puants si je puis dire
ils sont est très mauvais fallait le
faire et ça a été vraiment la caricature
du règne finissant c'est à dire avec un
roi qui s'en allait il perdait un oeil
et l'a perdu complètement ses jambes il
y avait des membres qui se détachaient
la gangrène l'avait complètement ravagée
et l'esprit était toujours là il était
le roi de france y voulait rester sur un
trône qui était en fait un fauteuil
roulant
il meurt le 16 septembre 1824 à l'âge de
68 ans après avoir régné pendant près de
dix ans il est enterré en la basilique
saint denis dernière demeure des rois de
france louis xviii et le dernier des
souverains français à s'éteindre cours
de son règne la restauration des
bourbons montre que la révolution et
l'empiré n'ont pas réussi à briser le
lien entre la famille royale et le
peuple français
et pourtant la restauration de 1814 1830
reste l'une des périodes monarchique les
plus élitistes de l'histoire de france
selon les normes de l'époque le règne de
louis xviii est un succès si les travers
du roi était considérable à varize
gourmandise duplicité et insensibilité
sa force première était la manière dont
il comprenait son temps pour mettre fin
aux dissensions entre ses sujets il a
usé de sa capacité exceptionnelle a créé
l' équilibre
il a rétabli l'autorité de la monarchie
donner un rôle à la noblesse française
rendu hommage aux figures majeures de la
révolution et donner au peuple ce qu'il
désirait
la paix pourquoi donc le règne de louis
xviii et il réduit à une note en bas de
page
[Musique]
ils émettent à se comparer à son ancêtre
bourbon henri iv qui avait choisi lui
aussi l'amnistié et la réconciliation
après les guerres de religion mais ce
n'est pas sous cet aspect que l'histoire
a retenu le nom de louis xviii henri iv
était un héros aux multiples facettes
ce qui contribue à faire oublier ses
défauts al'inverse les succès de louis
xviii ont sans doute été éclipsé par ses
faiblesses napoléon est à l'origine
d'immenses pertes pour la france d'une
certaine façon il a ramené la révolution
dans le pays
mais sa façon de passer d'un extrême à
l'autre son immense gloire et ses
défaites tragiques ont toujours enflammé
l'imagination populaire lui ont permis
de rester présent dans les mémoires
en comparaison la modération vertu
majeure de louis xviii n'a par
définition
rien de spectaculaire qui n'est pas donc
on parle pas beaucoup c'est pourtant un
souverain qui a su rétablir la monarchie
dans des conditions pas trop mauvaise il
a surtout dans permis la renaissance de
la france en fait après l' empire le
pays est sorti complètement épuisé
exemple des années de guerres
napoléoniennes et donc le 18 a rétabli
la paix et rétablit aussi une certaine
prospérité économique c'est déjà pas si
mal
d'autre part le libéralisme relative du
règne de louis xviii a été éclipsé par
le règne désastreux qui a succédé il va
être remplacé par son frère le comte
d'artois devenu charles 10
[Musique]
celui ci avec les membres du parti ultra
ont toujours été partisan d'accorder
davantage de pouvoirs aux souverains et
à l'église comme louis xviii l'avait
prédit
il ne fallut pas longtemps avant qu il
ne suscite le mécontentement général
ce gouvernement conservateur tente aura
d'introduire des mesures qui ne
rappelait que trop l'ancien régime honni
charles d'ici là supprimer énormément de
liberté que louis xviii avait autorisé
est donc cette continuation de louis
xviii charles 10 abouti en tête à une
nouvelle révolution
le visage modéré de la restauration
disparaissant la classe moyenne va se
révolter dans un soulèvement populaire
connu sous le nom de révolution de
juillet
[Applaudissements]
les violences exercées au nom de la
république menèrent la france loin des
nobles objectifs révolutionnaires et
c'est ainsi que la population cru aux
promesses de gloire et de stabilité de
napoléon
[Musique]
celui-ci entrepris certaines réformes
administratives et judiciaires
nécessaires mais son ambition militaire
le poussa dans des conquêtes sans fin
épuisée par dix ans de campagne la
france se retourna vers la monarchie
qu'elle avait délaissé le pays avait
besoin d'une constitution libérale et
d'une monarchie exécutive forte pour que
l'équilibré soit maintenue à la mort de
louis xviii
le peuple sortis en masse dans les rues
pour lui rendre hommage
ce qui révèle que pour beaucoup de ces
sujets louis xviii avait atteint ses
objectifs
la restauration des bourbons prend fin
en 1830
mais le combat de la nation pour
atteindre la maturité politique ne fait
que commencer
la france va devoir revisiter
différentes formes de gouvernement
la république puis à nouveau l'an pire
avant de trouver enfin sa voie